[Music]
can you hear me now can you hear me now
can you hear me now can you hear me can
you hear me
is it working am i back on line hello
hello how about now oh you can hear me
now okay oh boy I don't know what
that'll happen
it was registering my mic was doing the
audio levels were bouncing it was on the
right thing
I just restarted OBS and suddenly you
can hear me now this OBS is [ __ ]
broken I don't know what's wrong with it
anyway back to the dramatic opening of
this that I did welcome to welcome to
the game we are ready because I now have
a guide and I've read up on how to play
this game and the general consensus is
this game [ __ ] hard okay so this game
is hard as [ __ ] imagine that if
everything in the game was designed to
piss you off you've pretty much got the
idea of what this game is all about
protip don't forget the flashlight well
[ __ ] me then alright so last time we
played this game we got relatively
decently far we got two of the codes we
managed to avoid a little bit of death
but we didn't manage to avoid everything
but that doesn't mean that we're [ __ ]
it's more likely that we're [ __ ] but
it doesn't mean that we're [ __ ] don't
tell anybody that we're [ __ ] because
we actually aren't to problematically
bad about this
so the door's unlocked I haven't even
gotten in the goddamn game the door
can't be a lot well actually the door
probably is unlock just shut the [ __ ] up
Adnan I don't need you okay so the first
thing that we need to do is get this
from him we need to get this from him we
need to do all that [ __ ] we need to
order we need we need to [ __ ] disk
turn this off just turn it off in
general so the threats are as follows if
I can get up from this computer the
threats are as false
number one the police the police are
defeated by simply just going around and
connecting to different wi-fi's all the
time if you hear the police on the way
through the siren through the open
window over there that means that
they're on the way but you can defeat
them by turning off your computer and
they're just hiding in the shower so
they don't know which apartment then you
would be in and therefore you can go
away from them but you can still defeat
them and not waste time by just flipping
in between different areas makes sense
okay so the next thing that we need to
do is watch out for the new war the film
the war lock the door oh yeah the door
it's locked okay locked okay so the new
war are actually pretty easy to beat all
you got to do is look away for 30
seconds they can appear at the window
the door or pretty much anywhere in the
apartment but all you have to do is once
you find them turn around and they won't
be a problem anymore
yes I got oh I swear I've got the door I
got the door I swear the door is locked
it's as locked as it can be okay anyway
I'll explain the next one and while I'm
on the way to go get the VPN because the
next one would be Lucas Lucas is the
hitman 47 looking [ __ ] that
shoots you at random throughout the
entire game he's a piece of [ __ ] and he
should know that he's a piece of [ __ ]
but he can be avoided there is the
possibility that he can get you in the
apartment and I haven't been able to
find a common answer of whether or not
that is broken or it's just a random
event or something like that but either
way sound is a big part of what he does
you got it explore you basically got to
be in your apartment with the lights off
to generally have a good idea of whether
or not you're going to survive because
when he goes to your door you gotta
listen for him picking the lock and then
you have to sorry I thought I saw
something you got a pic you gotta wait
for him to try to pick the lock but then
you get
turn off all your lights and then yeah
turn off all your lights and then you
gotta turn off your computer and hide in
the shower and wait for him to go away
and that waiting can take up to five
minutes to go away a little problematic
when I'm trying to stream and talk to
you guys it locks it so it's a lock the
toilet that's a good idea so the other
threat is actually the breather who
appears in this very hallway I was
wondering why this door existed well
it's because the breather can come
basically screw up your entire day by
being right here in this alleyway and
when you went when he arrives there's
like two steps that signify he's gonna
be there and he'll try this door while
you're in this okay for a second there I
thought he was actually coming this way
he'll try this door while you're in this
alley he'll walk up to it very slowly
and he'll try it something like ten
different times it's really douchey
excessively douchey but you can beat him
and it's not that big of a deal I don't
know if he appears anywhere else in the
area which he very much might but if he
does then I don't know how to beat him
because I don't think there's any other
door that you can do that mechanic at
but I think that's part of the problem
so once you get that beaten then you
have one more threat which is actually I
think that might be it it's Lucas the
police eventually there's the dollmaker
but I don't know a lot about the
dollmaker because the guide that didn't
actually tell me about the dollmaker
Lucas okay I still know what would
happen if Lucas was just there and I
would be shot indeterminately I guess if
I had some kind of like camera system
set up but I don't have enough money for
that but one of the ways that I can get
money is by taking this and putting it
out on the area's now though I was
confused of like oh boys aren't anywhere
did I actually pick it up yeah I did so
if it's red it's a bad place for it if
it's yeah
that's a mediocre place for it what you
want to look for is the places where
it's green Oh was that green or was that
yellow I think it might have been yellow
yeah you want to look for where it's
green green is good because green is
gonna get you the most dose point now
probably level two is another place
where it's gonna be the most green
that's where one of them got placed or
level five or wherever that was I can't
remember what you guys said okay this is
all red red red red yellow okay
you guys probably know lock your glasses
I can't lock my glasses I can't lock my
butthole I can't lock my peepee I can't
do it guys it's impossible I don't know
what you want from me there's there's
literally no way that I can lock myself
up any tighter
lock the but I can't lock the but locked
the dollmaker doesn't make any sense you
guys need to think rationally locked
yeah that's one way to be this game just
lock everything if you just could do
that man you wouldn't have to worry but
alas I have to worry let me see let me
see in like one of these other floors
cuz I guess I can't go in there I don't
think that's how this game works guys I
don't think that's how it seems like
there's not a lot of potential here
please tell me somebody on this floor
once I just want to find the other plate
was that green goddamn it I keep
thinking it's green baby ok so I found
another spot hell yeah all right so I
want to find more of those just because
I want every single one of my VPNs to be
on a green spot gathering the most
dogecoin that I possibly could get lock
Ethan locked chica lock your pants lock
the universe lock the dog a barricade
the stairs locked please somebody lock
the police lock mouth protect your
butthole lock the bed lock the bite you
guys are funny ok so the other thing
that I want to do is I want to turn off
the lights
in the apartment because the lights you
know you don't even really need them to
be perfectly honest you don't need them
and number two I think the only one that
you'll need to do is buy this table here
because what that means is that I can
basically on the way into the bathroom I
can turn off everything yeah that's
thumpy you can turn off everything and
then the apartment will be off you turn
your computer off on the way back and
then everything is hunky-dory make sense
okay so we're here and I don't know if
the game completely games over if you
don't get everything done by the end of
this particular night I don't know if it
resets to the next night like it did in
the first game it would carry over
between nights then the nights actually
moved a lot faster but something tells
me that we might not have all the time
that we think we did all right let's go
okay time to play the game for real so I
won the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm gonna okay how much dogecoin am I
making a good bit point oh five so
that's the same as much as we were
before so now we just need to get our
notepad up and running and we just need
to start going through the internet
regularly checking for both for both
this world and yadda yadda yadda huh
come on let me make this bigger okay and
the other thing that I can do is I can
buy this but I mean I'm gonna need that
eventually but just not right now
so we're just gonna go top to bottom
we're not gonna ignore any of these if I
ever get a page that doesn't load then I
need to look at the window because
there's a pasta oh boy hey baby welcome
back oh yeah this is the bug share
people thing okay there's also something
about the source code I don't know if
the source code is something that I need
but uh I don't know it's just something
all right bug login join now FAQ yeah
lock the world lock the pizza I don't
have any pizza lock my shirt I can't
even
understand that oh I didn't lock the
door oops I didn't actually forgot to do
all the jokes I completely forgot to
lock my door
alright um oops [ __ ] oops my bad yo
okay alright then everybody wants some
spit anybody want some semen blood rough
and dirty oh boy I don't I don't want
any of that noise no plug in found okay
I should probably be breaking into a
wireless network right now but alas I am
NOT gonna do that because I'm dumb okay
let's actually do that let's get that
started because I want to want to make
sure that I can get that let's see if I
remember how to do it right which I
probably don't okay scan know what Oh
WEP scan okay so that's gonna be
scanning while we're doing that let's go
to someplace else so that we can get I
don't think there's there might be
something here but then again there
might not be I think a lot of the
strategies like revolve around possibly
possibly FZ XD no come on
XE g v NQ WG BAM
damnit oh yeah probe one to a thousand
go baby go oh god damn it one a thousand
go baby go okay yeah a lot of it has to
do with there's an item that you can get
that would potentially give you
everything that you would possibly need
okay looking looking nothing quite as
the Dickens
quiet as the Dickens okay all right it's
fine everything's fine so as soon as I
get this Wi-Fi I'm gonna remember to
write it down I'm gonna switch to a
different Wi-Fi I'm gonna hit all the
free Wi-Fi first don't worry about that
I'm gonna hit all the free Wi-Fi no I
just went there no please don't know I
just went there son of a [ __ ] the
fridge what's wrong what's wrong with
the fridge what are you talking about
the fridge there's something about the
fridge I can't lock the fridge I can't
lock the cold cube what are you talking
about
there's nothing to do lock the lock lock
the lock they'll never know
all right all right nothing okay you
hear that no you didn't hear nothing
because there was nothing there to hear
all right I okay open port on what was
the command it was crack let's crack
whoa [ __ ] hell I all right
what was it 7:37 23 channel 8 723 8 know
that god damn it 723 8 crack there we go
okay so that's cracking that what is
this do I even want to know what this is
okay all right I can't lock the [ __ ]
locking the [ __ ] isn't something that I
can do uh source No
okay this is just nothing okay that's a
whole lot of nothing I don't know I
don't even understand what that's
supposed to be but it's a whole lot of
nothing okay all right I'm dead I'm not
dead I'm very clearly alive to be
perfectly honest I'm more alive than
I've ever been
okay password has been 2000 so D five
nine seven oh nine Pass pass mm okay so
I got that let's move wi-fi's disconnect
baby
all right let's move let's go by the
windowsill by the windowsill and then
while we're on the free Wi-Fi I will go
ahead and scan another one
ooh there's two free Wi-Fi okay let's
scan scanning go back window look at the
eye I'm not dead I've locked I can't
lock it there's no way that you could
possibly do that doesn't make any sense
okay
fifty-seven random mysterious page all
right let's probe R 0 VL + q v v 0r one
to a thousand please alright nothing
there anybody there all right forgive me
I don't know if I want to confess my
sins I just don't know just not 100%
sure about that alright oh we haven't
gone yet man there's a slow Wi-Fi
secretly confess your sins hi I'm Brent
and I love feet way too much especially
those cute little toes yeah me too Brett
maybe two men all right [ __ ] the FBI
they won't give me that's not a
confession I bought an anime a body
pillow without telling my wife I don't
know why I'm reading all these in a
southern accent in hoc habet ah say plot
a a dick to soms
I've send a lot of dick thumbs to myself
there viv ahh --mess de Amado samay all
right anything in the source code submit
my confession anybody here let me just
check the people I'm just paranoid about
it no one oh cool we're good we're good
did we find a probe hey we did okay
let's let's six seven to channel 12
let's crack that bad boy wide open
crack go all right I am so sorry about
the badger incident of 1994 that was my
bad
in my defense it was a misunderstanding
between the Badger and myself I didn't
know that worked
it's badger that's allowed to [ __ ] all
right well I was gonna say I didn't know
that fireworks were not badger
compatible did I get it okay so [ __ ]
every time every [ __ ] time it scares
the piss out of me
[ __ ] you I can't lock the Badger I can't
do it it's impossible [ __ ] scared
well [ __ ] that up real hard okay here we
go
block bonus monies cheese scared the
piss one three eight two four four five
pass is 420 420 got it okay let's move
to another Wi-Fi let's check to see if
anybody's here scared the bejesus out of
me you have I have a poop this is a good
personal problem there okay I didn't see
anything in the confession I don't think
anything opened up there but maybe it
did and I didn't notice it to be
perfectly honest I'm not 100 percent
sure anybody would have noticed that I
don't think there was any other free
Wi-Fi to crack here so we got a go your
game cat expect pleasure
I don't expect pleasure from game cat I
don't think
all alt f4 equals lock tiny locked - you
guys
soles funny you guys were hilarious all
right whatever okay we're good all right
okay nothing there hackers for hire let
me actually go ahead and buy one of
those backdoor hacks yeah zone wall does
not count why does zone wall not count
doesn't make any sense whatever I guess
you need to fail that first one so that
you can actually get the possibility of
any other extraneous hacks because you
need the extra hacks to be able to make
money because that's just an easy way to
get money from those hacks even though
the hacks are are a problem but whatever
hail Satan
hail Satan lock Satan lock he'll lock
the lock lock the bad guys lock the
lights lock my pants you guys lock
Burger King all right okay well can't
connect al Satan massive stuff is a
problem all right so if you're just
paranoid enough about this game you
should be able to survive pretty much
anything that it throws at you right I
guess all right heirloom sperm sperm
collection storefront great all right
sports / mmm my own making I don't know
what this PGP key is what is that all
about I don't want to know I don't know
quality let's look at the quality of
this whatever the hell let's look at the
quality presented here
can you know oh boy oh why does it keep
highlighting I don't want to highlight
anything shut your eyes lock your eyes
everybody lock him let's just move this
and Oh can't move it in front well it's
just oh boy huh lock the sperm nope
mm-hmm nope okay you know what let's
look make sure we're not gonna die okay
all right containers okay
all right lock my soul please tell me
there's a code on this website it would
have to be worth the price why does it
keep highlighting highlight oh god
special orders anybody please someone
end my torment just make me not have to
do this to be perfectly honest I'd
rather not experience anything that's
happening here right now hair looms oh
there's nothing there's nothing okay
[Music]
terrifying terrifying terrifying okay
let's let's not do zone wall all right
here we go no oh my worst
oh no worst worst one all right let's go
here let's go there come on please just
please please oh my god so no it's so
why is that one so hard by none of these
work that once oh god the window is open
now well that's good actually because
then when the window is open you can
actually
when the window is open you can actually
hear stuff outside which is beneficial
to be perfectly honest but it also means
they could know that what is impossible
that one specifically compared to every
other one there that one is impossible
why why do they make that ones so
difficult I don't get it could not
validate your wall this was a big-ass
waste of time there's no point of any of
that all right we got a switch wi-fi's
all right let's just disconnect oh my
god that's so [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] I plopped you all right
clapped huh lock the mmm you can't
reclose the window what are you what are
you what are you stupid
what are you just guessing here come on
what do you lock my dog I can't it's
impossible good schoo oh god let's go
what the Frick
oh I'm not connected that's right duty
all right let's scan what we got here
scan go home please
another backdoor heck yeah 375 that
would be nice that would be nice
wouldn't it okay let's probe EK h md-82
BD t5 BAM nope
1 mm all right let's go baby why are we
not going why are we not why are we not
going hello can we go please could we go
get out of here
nothing yet looks safe
alright let's go to hidden pleasures mmm
no no don't like that no nope lock my
channel that's gonna help anybody oh boy
it's doing that highlight thing again
stop highlighting [ __ ] it's like is it's
almost too perfect and emulation of real
browser how do you frickin make it not
do that or whatever [ __ ] why just
stop ah alright whatever
[ __ ] boggy [ __ ] alright message I
don't know if any of this is what I want
highly recommend you have your purchase
tested upon receiving that's wonderful
to hear
that's great okay alright let's go
a new security system home nope post a
sale I got a virus I didn't get a virus
oh god now I didn't want to go home I
wanted oh crap that's not what I wanted
well I've got to go back there well
that's loading let me check to make sure
there's no one at my door okay block the
yogurt CL okay
um sale requests did I get it okay let's
do 939 channel is three probe to crack
go baby go alright does any of these
work probably not hello I I am young
wealthy man by the name of poopy I have
a strong large [ __ ] clinches are as
you can I hope I don't get the stupid
one alright here we go ah perfect
something I can no one cool by
comparison
that's so comparatively easy it's not
even remotely closely fair it's not even
close okay I found the password okay so
that one was what was that one
[Music]
oh boy all right we have a problem okay
I can't even people everything fine he's
fine everything's fine everything is
totally fine
lock that door everything's totally fine
okay I was in the middle of something
thank you but alas I am no longer let's
go back on duty and let's get another
one of these and let's write down for
food sir is pass Disney got it
okay we're only gonna stay on this for a
little bit longer in fact actually I
should probably just change it wide
there we go okay
okay
I thought I heard something ooh I
probably did hear something whoa ah what
the [ __ ] look the [ __ ] okay all right
then
uh yeah I wish you could lock the back
door that would be awfully nice but alas
no okay okay all right we're fine
everything's fine everything's totally
fine okay
everything's fine so we got to get on
another one and then we get they know
they know they know they know so how are
you
they know they know they know I'm here
they know I'm here they're gonna come to
my door and they're gonna break in their
gonna try to stop me but I won't be
stopped I can't be stopped
it's gonna go poorly for me but that was
definitively the alert everybody clench
your buttcheeks as hard as you can
because it is about to get real in here
I don't know if I'm actually hearing
that Murph
that's just my imagination I also don't
know if
okay
it might be okay might be it might be of
just passing cuz I mean I just switched
I just switched network so it might have
all been a goof if it was a goof I think
it was just a goof I think it was just a
goof
okay I think I think it was
I think there was just uh I think there
was just uh passing I think there was a
passing police not to me
I think that was just I'm pretty sure
that was just a passing police presence
not for me
must have been right must must have been
ma must have been must have been passing
fluky [ __ ] yeah that's what it was
let's go on free Wi-Fi no virus
all right let's scan this bad boy I
think we're fine I think I mean I wasn't
on those for very long so I imagine I
don't know all right whatever it's
probably fine
probably yeah yeah I don't like it but
you know what can you do about it
okay I think I'm fine let's go to hot
burners there might have been something
on hidden pleasures but I'm not
obviously how would I know how would I
even remotely know okay okay man this
game I will admit like I had some
complaints about this game last time but
it does it is scary like it's it's a
tense game if you want a game that's
just tense it's like this is that kind
of game it's I mean it's just like that
it just is it's 100% tense it's tension
to the extreme okay Illuminati three
three three is that the number of the
Illuminati cuz I don't even know okay
nothing I'm getting a whole lot of
nothing here alright let's let's know
four five seven channel is seven packet
wide open okay let's go to little
friends not that I want to just that
it's what I have to it must spill over
to multiple days there's no way that you
could beat this game in one night
there's no way you could even get enough
money in a single night right there just
be no way okay mortal masks some [ __ ]
up dudes selling human faces that's nice
to know that's real nice no no god I
wish this highlighting thing would
[ __ ] go away home how do I do it how
do you do it how do you do it man how do
you how do you do it man you're so
talented okay it's almost time for me to
buy another VPN I've got 25 right now
actually I rinsed the mask in bleaching
mixture followed by alcohol afterwards I
place a mask on it sandal did the
alcohol evaporate which dries them out
no paint this
yup hate this hate hate this hate this
hate it $75 I don't know don't want any
of that actually don't want none of that
okay we cracked it okay so Wi-Fi af1 a 5
5 D is password is stupid okay perfect
wonderful I guess alright so that's all
of the free Wi-Fi but I think I can stay
on this one a little bit longer I'm
being as cautious as I can
[Music]
that's a code eight five two nine seven
six eighty five left seven okay all
right hey hate that hate that I'm out
I'm Audi I got a code you know what
actually I'm gonna just what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna order the VPN and I'm
going to I'm gonna log off this one
disconnect that we got that we've got
that let's just turn off the computer in
general I think is it still ship if I'm
not on the internet probably but let's
just move the Wi-Fi Dumble anyway just
cuz I don't feel comfortable don't like
any of that don't like that at all
okay let's let's move it back to the
desk I don't know does it reset when you
um when you does it reset the police's
ability to find you if you go back to
the same one but it's been a while you
know I haven't been on tp-link in ages
but I I'm just not a hundred percent
sure I just barely touched it I
literally just touched it come on pack
block game fifteen again what I get in
15 I don't even know about that
that seems awful that seems wrong okay
you know what I'm powering off because
I'm gonna what I'm gonna do I hear a
whooshing and I don't like the whooshing
sound but my you guys hear that
whooshing that's just the cars going by
okay so I'm uh what I'm gonna do is uh I
don't know if it's gonna help but I'm
gonna turn off all the lights in my
apartment again I don't know if it's
actually gonna help but I'm just gonna
do it anyway
I don't know what causes Lucas to shoot
me in the face if I come back up here
and he's suddenly there but uh just
gonna take it nice and easy okay
lock the whoosh I can't I can't lock the
whoosh the ocean can't be locked it
can't be contained all right but I'm
gonna have a double VPN and I'm gonna
have more points coming my way and I'm
actually gonna put them in a good spot
so I'll have double the currency coming
up but I mean I'm I'm impressed that I
got as much money as I did from that
hack block which is considerable yeah
again I don't know if shutting off your
computer or turning everything off or
turning the lights off is actually gonna
help in any way man could I just hang
out down here
that'd be awfully nice wouldn't it if I
just sit around in the lobby and not
worry
I follow I thought I heard something I
thought I did and then I turned around
that was my mistake turning around I
thought I heard something I should have
just gone straight for the door man come
on is so unforgiving God and I have to
do all of the cracking over again don't
peek too much what does that mean
what does that mean from the shower oh
my god I knew I heard something it was
weird it was like this splishy-splashy
sound I don't know it just wasn't normal
oh god damn it
all right that's fine that's the
breather for everyone who didn't know
who that was that is the breather the
breather gets you in the alleyway
sometimes I wasn't a hundred percent
sure because I was only reading a guide
as to what it was of course
okay I need sky break I need one of
these and I need to go get the VPN let's
shut everything down
[ __ ] of course of course a horse of
course a horse a horse of course god
damn it scared the piss out of me my
heart's still going a million miles an
hour
yeah yeah all right let's go get her
okay yeesh
yeah that's why it like this game is
legitimately scary I still think the
game is overly punishing but I guess the
risk of it does make it intensely
nerve-wracking so I guess that's part of
it and whatever this game design will
all right I'm gonna be on my head's
gonna be honest wobble let's do this way
tries all hard but you don't succeed I
agree I agree it's [ __ ] all right
right here come I don't think it's gonna
get you in the drones there you know I
just have a funny feeling
thank you
it's not ok not ok maybe the first maybe
the first step should just be I should
run for the room no matter what I do if
I'm going outside I should just go
straight for the room not look back not
look back like I just did not look back
go straight for the room I hope for the
best and then that's the end of it like
I don't know any other way to possibly
do this other than that I'm just gonna
go in my room I'm gonna grab the thing
I'm a boogie Audi I'm gonna put it where
a 6th floor was a good spot I could try
to find another spot just to put it in
my brain because I know on the door of
the fifth floor is a good spot it was it
the second floor I can't even remember
okay no one's gonna shoot me here lock
the drone I can't lock the drone the
drone cannot be locked I just grabbed it
[ __ ] Audi no one's here okay cool
let's go let's go
let's all go lots of yellow spots but
what would be even be the point of
putting it on a yellow spot I don't even
know can't go there red red yellow okay
let me try something else besides the
sixth floor it was it the fifth floor
yeah the fifth floor is one we see if
there's anything inside the fifth floor
that's also good I'm just doing this for
future helping miss do yellow a lot of
yellow yellow seems like this is all
yellow
I wouldn't have suspected that on the
flip floor there would be something else
but you never know you never know all
right whatever primo spot let's just do
it I wonder if there's like it better
than green maybe like a super super
dongle space the VPN in bathroom that
might that might work there there might
be I wouldn't be surprised if they put
something like that where you least
expect it to be okay well we got the VPN
setup we can get to cracking passwords
again unless they're the same password
which I bet they're not they would not
be I guarantee they would not be
okay the lights that go on let's go for
it let's get e maybe I could just play
with the lights off but that also seems
dangerous not a hundred percent sure
about that
initializing that let's get our notes
back up gotta start over again gotta
start over with this [ __ ] found
something good and then it's just gone
oh yeah gotta connect first that help
right scan no WEP scan alright let's do
this
hmm I'm not gonna gift the Fox that's
not even the right game it's not even
the right genre alright let's see I
don't even want to know what was even
though it was even the website that I
went to is like hot burners or something
like that alright but either way we're
gonna start at the top again
alright probe TCP cat pk6 uu7 the CQ one
to a thousand please nothing there
nothing there
oops no no no okay burn at the stake
lock the door the door you're right
block the door that's important probably
oh sorry
[Laughter]
you always forget that silly me as
Millie's Millie see silly me I'm gonna
try I'm gonna try just plated with a
lights off see what that does for me
even though it kind of makes it a lot
more obvious of what's happening here
whatever let's just do this is really
bad for my eyes probably all right
unable to connect great anybody there
how would I know I can't [ __ ] see
alright listen let's actually turn it's
spooky in the dark it's spooky okay ah
chosen awake are you awoke not I'm not a
woke I'm I'm the opposite of awoke and
nothing alright well that's great okay
God hold on nothing mm-hm
[Laughter]
spoopy yeah indeed spoopy dream place
mmm no six seven one channel eight crack
cracker there we go
nothing man I've been having bad luck
here I wonder if it's like you can if
there's like a minute time that you can
be on a certain certain thing Oh found
it already alright D five nine seven oh
nine is pass is Brian oh there we go
okay let me go ahead and crack the other
one scan those are a skinny ok drove
videos what have you got
lock my ears lock the gif doesn't mean
you're not making any sense now robe
it's 0 0 C 6 vs 8 l 3 3 go ok bye for me
if the spoop that's not how it works
face cam audio out of sync that doesn't
even make sense how would that work it's
it's just a stream I don't understand I
don't understand it it seems to be
working for is it out of sync for
anybody else or is that just just
something that someone's saying okay
that didn't work now we got a whole lot
nothing we got up we got a hit let's go
crack tu-95 channel 8 0 0 c 6 the c 6 vs
8 l 3 3 go okay on crave do not break
the 9 I don't understand what you mean
by break the 9 I don't even know if I
want to know what you mean by break the
9 go away oh do not break the 9 I didn't
want to break the 9 to be perfectly
honest I had no intention of breaking
the 9 Blackwater's hold the ground from
us but we will have control of them in
the ad do not
stand for this apparently okay I am the
Lord
oh that's unpleasant
oh that's very unpleasant okay found it
SS Wi-Fi Pass is suck me suck me okay
let's go ahead and hop off this lets hop
off that cuz frankly I didn't want to
look at that anymore move it over to the
window
doodlee do okay connect back up wink and
scan let's do this I know I've been
saying that a lot this is because I
don't want to die I know there was a
noise but it doesn't seem like anyone's
there so what am I to do hello nice
third eye alright let's go
probe ti9 p PX z 3a k 1000 please go
alright the gate is open you have been
warned the ground is dunder feet in
under our feet okay well that's weird
why what is that some kind of zalgo
[ __ ] oh the ground is dead under our
feet okay alright well that's lovely not
helpful but lovely okay I don't know why
whatever the door is locked it is I
can't eat the fridge the door's locked
everything's fine to the window to the
wall you don't even make sense here
you're not even I don't even understand
what you're talking about you gonna die
yeah I'm pretty sure yeah that makes
sense I'm pretty sure that's accurate
yeah okay nothing there okay can you
lock the window no you can lock nothing
besides the door even despite what chad
is hoping for the door is the only thing
that you can lock 5:43 let's see channel
12 go alright 57
nothing yet okay no hacks yet either
which is confusing ah well that was fast
okay pwf one three eight two four two
four four five four five pass Jackson
got it okay I'm gonna hang on this one
just a little bit longer well actually
there's two free Wi-Fi so I might as
well switch were there two I don't think
there was two different places for this
right probably not yeah it was just the
one okay that's fine audio is faster
than webcam that doesn't even make any
sense
Wow whatever it's probably close enough
that is barely noticeable so I'm not
gonna there's literally nothing that I
could do about it at this juncture I
would dry my best but I can
flame I don't even know what that's
gonna do
don't peep too much I don't think I can
peep too much here
what is peeping too much gonna do for me
here at my chair
oh god it's a whole lot of nothing
you're being goofed yeah I'm pretty sure
I am streams perfect that's what I
thought that's what I thought that's
what I thought
all right let's go to the foot doctor if
let's not go to the foot doctor but
apparently we have to go to the foot
doctor I don't want to go the foot
doctor but we're gonna go to the foot
doctor apparently right also I got a pee
real bad okay my name is Raymond and I
love feet all kinds from anyone concept'
conventional methods of seeing feet ages
ago okay oh no okay none of these are
clickable all right my favorite feet all
right sure great okay no no no it's the
dongles fine we just switched to a
different Wi-Fi on the same location so
we should be fine for a good bit longer
okay all right well this is weird
okay okay homemade homemade feet how do
you hold me how do you home make feet I
guess you make another human I guess but
no I don't think I'm gonna like this
okay ah amateur feet is what we're
talking about here great great great
okay we can arrange a payment plan so I
just send this guy pictures of my feet
and I make money I can retire from
YouTube then I just gotta send people
pictures of my feet okay there was
nothing here anything in the source code
probably not don't look it all right
let's get out
now we need people to hack me so I can
make some money I need enough if 13 daus
coin bomb like I just had [ __ ] you yep
pretty much says it all okay you know
what mama alright whatever
sure sure thing fine by me the foot
doctor is coming for you same as the
dollmaker the foot mockers the foot
mockers the foot doctors pretty much the
same
nope nothing there okay cool
where do you sign up find out sign up
for my feet that was a joke it's one of
those joke things that's not that's not
it's not how this one didn't it's not
gonna happen
hackers for hire I don't think hackers
for hire worked last time but I'm gonna
try
all right after this website I'm gonna
switch whoa oh god that chair I thought
that was a guy holding his arms behind
his head for a second there all right
what do we got nope nothing guys just a
whole lot of nothing walk the cheesie's
that doesn't make any sense that doesn't
make any sense at all hidden pleasures
worked last time I don't know if it's
gonna work again but
it's only ten-thirty just now I've heard
that things only start to get weird
after 10:30 so yeah probably should
worry about that okay let's go to 46 to
55 really the age range that I'm
interested in
unlock the door lock my virginity I'm
gonna keep that so protected no one's
gonna get near all right um I don't
think this is gonna get anywhere I just
have to like message or something I
don't know the milkman oh wow every time
every time every time every time see
what you got for me please don't be that
connect-the-dots [ __ ] and that'd be
nice please oh god is to connect the
dots [ __ ] okay here we go I got that
one that's not right no this one that
one this one that that one this one and
that one yes I did it I [ __ ] did it
brave holy [ __ ] I did it a message to
seller submit thank you I did it I never
do that one I never got it I just have
to click like a [ __ ] huh lock the
dots okay okay we got 16 daus coin by
the way just for anybody it's curious
okay I don't know what that's gonna do
I'm gonna hop off this Wi-Fi cuz I need
to as soon as this loads the next page
because of problem cause problems okay
get Nancy oh my bladder is incredibly
full that's TMI that you don't need to
know but let's hop off disconnect and
let's get yeah okay we're gonna move to
the
okay how do I it makes a fabric he
sticky sound whenever I lay that down oh
well it doesn't really matter
duty scan alright let's go back home
refresh hmm look at lactating women I
don't want to I just don't want to you
know I I just don't want to h4y eat
Niner z2 up lit book Z 2 GJ Oh Frick
okay there we go um hot burners did it
go there I don't think I went there yet
I think I did I just did didn't I I
can't remember
I I hate that it doesn't like gray out
the websites that you have been to but
they didn't load I just causing more
problems for me okay yeah I probably
just went there I wish I would open my
window because that would help me out
because then I'd be able to hear some
goddamn [ __ ]
alright I love cats meow I remember this
website it's not fun it's not a good
website it's very not good oh boy I love
cats
something about cats me human don't
wanna pet me my cats me human nope
oppan to use this as a convenient excuse
I'm gonna use this as an excuse to go to
the bathroom
are we dead we're fine right okay
okay everything's fine right nothing
happened while I was away what happened
while I was away did anything happen did
you guys hear noises you seem to be
panicking over something so I'm going to
assume that you've heard some noises
happening all right that was the most
nervous pee of my life
all right where am i okay all right we
got an open port on this so let's whoo
all right 907 channel 3 we're gonna
crack this one okay this didn't work
let's go oh yes I wash my hands thank
you very much
huh come on let's go home why are we not
going home oh I'm not connected that's
right
okay password found cool we got this so
f LTE our passes Jimmy okay come on
let's go jeez let's go okay there was
another one there was another server to
hack here oh [ __ ] they got it they got
my window
they opened my window they opened my
window they opened it okay that's okay I
think it's fine let me go back to we
love cats I can't type anymore
tn Oh j6w one to a thousand please okay
my cats I guess okay it's fine
okay nothing here nothing here nothing
here nothing you're nothing clickable
looks like nothing okay Pat I don't know
what that means
oh that's the contact I don't want to go
there that doesn't help anybody yeah
so now I got to be extra careful because
the nor could be nearby oh [ __ ] you can
I didn't know you could angle Oh No well
that's awful
I don't like that at all okay but I
think it's okay okay that's this cars
that's cars it's cars okay I don't think
there's anything here
lock the door the door is locked
it is locked huh - the window wall
walled window wall window yeah - the
window wall okay everything's fine okay
that didn't go anywhere milk supply oh
boy oh boy oh boy six four to channel
three crack it nope don't like this page
nope the milkman a 100% real breast milk
great okay awesome great mm-hmm no so
good for you yep so good for any more
milk pictures great let's let's do that
let's definitely do that I probably
shouldn't run while I'm in my apartment
because that that's yeah it's locked
done don't fool me you guys can't fool
me I know I know when it's locked
Oh found it okay Suddenlink 990 password
found Pass is speedy okay so that's both
for this let's hop off of this we need
to move it to the last place that we
need to go which is outside but
hopefully there's no one outside
okay let's just make a pact not to run
while we're in our apartment because
that makes noise and I don't want to
make noise okay
plop it there plop it plop it we're just
gonna calmly go from A to B if we calmly
go from A to B we can't possibly die
make sense okay let's go here
nice and quiet it's just a power outage
happens all the time
happens all the time with no problems no
problems at all
no problems no problems easy easy
there ain't no problems happening here
okay no problems no problems
easy peasy no problems no whammies no
whammies no whammies no whammies no
whammies no whammies no whammies
all right let's order another VPN I
don't want to go outside but I'm gonna
have to all right
robe l8 hy
86 5 P H X 1000 please I where are we I
don't even know the pictures that's
right
we're gonna have to go down to get it
and I don't want to get it but you know
this is the way it is okay I don't see
anything there's a 2 there but I don't
think that counts anything in the source
code probably not okay it doesn't look
like it
okay back home back home okay it's fine
lock the door you're right lock the door
got to do that that's important that's
him
nope that was bad okay I am frazzled I'm
miss frazil I'm frazzled dazzled
okay okay where am I milk's play Mortal
masks the [ __ ] up dude selling
zone faces don't like that 25 totally
fine totally fine totally fine totally
fine totally fine perfect I mean not
perfect but obviously that's what I
wanted seven 507 and five okay 707 to
perfect hell yeah baby oh no that's not
what I wanted god damn it Oh where'd you
go this one okay 504 Channel seven crack
crack okay let's look for anybody who
snuck into my apartment who did it who
did it okay okay my package is waiting
for me downstairs oh how do you do it
how are you so good at what you do
okay nothing their source code nothing
order okay Wi-Fi a f-105d pass is Canada
got it okay
okay home back to home
I'm getting nervous I'm getting nervous
okay we got that let's let's just go
ahead and go get the package because if
we don't do it now we're never gonna do
it and I'm gonna lose out on money so I
got to go get it I might as well cuz
yeah okay here we go here we go
everything's fine totally fine what
we're gonna do is we're gonna go
straight into that room no matter what
don't care what it is just gonna go for
it just gonna go for it and that's all
there is to it how does anybody browse
this Internet this is my main question
if the the Deep Web is like a populated
place how does it everybody get away
with it you know it doesn't make any
sense I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know okay I'm just gonna go
for it I'm gonna gun it the room no
problems didn't hear anything that time
but you know what ain't risking it you
close that I'm gonna get by the door
okay I think it's fine I think it's fine
it's totally fine totally fine got it
nailed it okay here we go whoo hey all
right
totally fine fine and dandy fine and
dandy fine and dandy
just going back to my apartment just
going back to my apartment
oh why does my where's my flashlight not
working uh
game-wise my where's my flashlight not
working
am i dead my debt I'm a my dad for some
reason I might yeah I'm I'm not dad
for summary what did I do I would like
to know what I did wrong if I'm about to
die I would like you to tell me what I
did
why is my flashlight now working hi you
can't lock the door on the way out you
can't do it you can't well I am gonna go
into the maintenance closet and I'm
gonna turn off the power
nope hiding here no I got no well think
I'm dead
yep hollow okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 all
right perfect excellent very happy about
this situation but my flashlight seems
to be gone don't know why well okay I
don't know how to get new batteries for
my flashlight that's what I don't know
how to do whoa apparently that's a
perfect spot for it generates a lot of
money there
can I have that okay let me check the
bathroom like you guys said how do you
I can't I can't go in the bathroom when
I have it I don't think I can place it
in my apartment okay yeah I don't know I
don't know change your flashlight I
don't think there's a way I don't think
that's something you can do I don't
think you could just do that little
thing you could do that all right where
was it on this wall this far down I
guess by halfway nope
more more more more more more no oh did
it change does it rent no it doesn't
randomly you can't write I thought it
was it was on the sixth floor I thought
oh no that was yellow I thought it was
am I on the wrong floor oh come on I
thought it was Oh wasn't it here wasn't
it here I thought it was here god damn
it of course not
yeah [ __ ] well all right then
you can't lock the door on the way out
you can't do it you can't do it you
can't do it you can't do it it's
impossible you guys are out of your
gourds all right let's try floor four
nope can't go even go in floor four we
got yellows we got yellows we got
yellows down here oh there we go green
baby all right perfect
no I bet we're gonna die somehow some
way we're probably gonna die going back
up to our own apartment don't know how
well it's gonna happen probably cuz I
didn't lock my butthole like everyone
told me to probably it's gonna sneaky
snog
sorry I just felt like crying for some
reason yeah so I guess I'm just boned
without the flashlight I don't know I
don't understand how I know I just don't
get it I don't get it I don't understand
it has anybody ever ran out of
flashlights before it's like the very
beginning of the game how would I run
out of flashlight that quickly you know
it doesn't make any sense I I would just
be boned right I would just be boned I'm
I am just boned I think I think that's
how that goes whatever I don't know if
there was there anything was there any
other one here let's just go home
connected yeah that was the only one
here all right won't stay on this for a
little bit longer I didn't lock I always
forget oh I always forget okay yep still
no flashlight okay
welcome to the myriad if you are with us
welcome our objective pain is needed to
reach peace not 100% sure that's true
mm-hmm okay all right good job very
supreme very supreme I'm very impressed
by your supreme miss
uh numbers station what are the numbers
mean you know what I actually add a spry
fine number station I didn't forget the
door
how do you think I just locked it I'll
go back but only to prove to you guys
that you're wrong and I'm right
see it's locked can't open it mm-hmm
can't open it nope can't open it see you
look crazy
flashlight is broken though flashlight
is completely bupkis don't know why I've
never I haven't heard of anybody running
out of flashlights before very bizarre
which means that I'm gonna be if the
power goes out again I am just boned I
will not be able to do anything about it
I think this game is just wait let me
let me hang on let me try something here
I'm gonna go to the main menu I don't
know when it's I don't know when the
last time it would have saved is it
would have saved every 15 minutes so it
would've been 11:15 right I'm gonna go
back to the menu I'm gonna load back in
maybe maybe I've got a flashlight I'm
hoping it's just bugged because I don't
know why it would be gone otherwise
right just hang on it's a bug I know
it's it's got to be a bug there's no
batteries in this and I've played longer
and I've had my flashlight for longer
buy batteries from the black market that
doesn't make any sense disconnecting a
network will prevent from being hacked
Platts tracked by the police yes okay
where am I it's dark oh I have
flashlight though okay wait what was
that
ah this is before really this is before
I turn no the powers not off I was oh
this is what the when was when was this
well I got my flashlight now so that's
all that matters okay uh Wi-Fi is we're
outside oh you've got to be oh no wait
no that would've been the last place
that I would have gotten it from right
so I've got everything right probably I
don't know I don't know when this is or
what this is about either way I got my
goddamn flashlight it's 1101 or whatever
I got Candida that's all that matters I
don't know where I am I don't know what
I'm doing I'm gonna connect to a network
we're going TP link and let's just do
this let's just do this hardcore mode
baby all my windows not even open cat
damn it's that far back whatever let me
see if there's there actually are
batteries and I don't think there are
yeah there's no there's nothing yeah
nothing yeah
okay alright let's start from number
station I think that was a dead website
I don't know man I don't even have my
window open that's really bizarre okay
oh do I have my second VPN oh no I think
I do do I do i I have my am I making
money yeah I'm making big money okay I'm
making big money I think I'm making big
money I don't know am I making big money
I think I'm making big money I can
making big money is the door locked
maybe the door locked it's not locked
okay it wasn't locked all right it's
fine it's fine fine you guys are
panicked over nothing worried about
locking up your buttholes I'll worry
about locking my door don't worry about
it I got it all right here we go let's
go to one list I don't know what one
list is but I'm running out of websites
is the thing I'm running out of websites
I don't know I do if I don't have those
oh [ __ ] well you had a number before now
you don't have a number so that's not
good or whatever I don't want to go
there I don't like that place oddly
enough I don't like that place okay
I'm gonna hop on actually I'm gonna hop
on d5 907 we're going Brian okay now
we're on a new Wi-Fi not too shabby
and that's gonna keep us a little
protected I guess use less flashlights
good idea bad idea I'm sorry it's bad
okay all right thank you for that thank
you
perfect perfect here we go
give me the good [ __ ] zero seven give me
money give me money give me money give
me money
all right I'm gonna buy more of those
there's easy money even if even if I
lose it doesn't lose all that much dass
so why not
all right let's see nothing jeez nothing
ever check the money and get better
Wi-Fi yeah it's very smart yes I know I
will do that as soon as I'm able to Sky
web I just went there the Grandaddy
dirty old pervert ah my favorite web
site perfect wonderful great but my next
my next idea is that I'm gonna get us
another one of the no not this
I'm your granddaddy mmm-hmm don't like
that oh god damn it my VPNs still
downstairs you know what I'm gonna don't
like this guy oh well my window is open
that's wonderful okay well my windows
open okay all right entry one I've never
been a monogamous man and young girl
certainly have no interest in no nope
nope nope nope don't like this nope does
not nope
you know what nope nope nope does it go
with a big old nope on this one this is
not nope I don't like this website just
don't mmm don't like it mmm toss coins
go away there's nothing here okay well
I'll leave then I hear the hey the road
now I think that's what I'm hearing okay
gray will you walk in the shade I don't
know if I will man I really don't know
if I will my VPN is outside but I'll get
it eventually
who will are the gray we will walk in
the shade
sure you will okay great great great
great great great grey grey grey grey
grey grey grey grey mattress do you want
to walk in the shade yes I do I haven't
even gotten a single code yet
I've got nothing I don't even know what
it wants for me okay are you ready to
begin lattice sure whatever men
nope hmm I'll turn the volume up for you
guys just to let you guys in on a little
more of what's happening here well that
way you can get jumpscared just as nice
as I am okay nope god it's just a bunch
of nothing it's it's just a bunch of
nothing it's just a non-stop
never-ending tower of nothing and I've
got nothing to my name and nothing to do
I just want enough to get two VPNs in
one go someone hacked me please
motion sensor yes I know I know I know
the VPNs outside I'll get it in a second
has nothing nothing nothing no code
nothing nothing in the source code
nothing return is just a whole lot of
nothing my life is gray yep I'm done
there's nothing here do I just need to
farm up enough money to be able to get
the key finder cuz that's the only thing
I could possibly imagine I don't even
know how anybody would beat this game
without it because they'd just be
trolling along these I guess eventually
if you upgrade your internet these pages
would load faster my internet is a pile
of dick so why not write there's only
like one more website don't enter the
hall well too late [ __ ] oh I'm going in
your Hall alright
why though whole lot of nothing yeah I
know
oh okay maybe I I don't like tall
oh I don't like the hall no but don't
like the hall hmm don't like oh don't
don't like the hall nope don't like the
hall I don't like that hall
I'd like the hall don't throw I don't
know I don't want to be the hall creepy
guy was on a new Wi-Fi when I switched
over to a new Wi-Fi and I didn't hear
any police was it cuz I went to the hall
god damnit don't go to the hall I guess
is the answer to that don't go to the
hall the long and the short of it is if
you go to the hall the hall will bone
you so just don't go to the hall don't
go to the hall yeah that was that was
way too early for police yeah that was
way too early because I literally just
transferred Wi-Fi to a new one like one
of the absolute new ones that I cracked
the password to so don't go to the hall
it must have also just been like my my
computer was making a lot of noise too
so that was probably a problem
[ __ ] I switched over to the police Wi-Fi
Oh is that even a possibility can you
really go to a Wi-Fi that's like
dedicated to police it's nothing oh
that's cool if that is a thing that's
that's pretty cool all right you know
what I'm going to do is actually I'm
going to I'm gonna save my coin this
time
and I'm gonna go straight for the I'm
gonna go straight for the VPN I'm not
gonna worry about buying the password
cracking because apparently I don't need
to do it anymore whatever is the big
waste but uh damn I didn't even knew
that got so many nuances of this game
that's looks like maybe this is a
problem maybe this is the thing that you
maybe just a whole lot of maybes like
everything's up in the air I don't like
being punished for things that I don't
know the rules to it's fine alright it's
fine we're gonna go get the VPN we're
gonna place down we're gonna do this
right we're gonna get some money we're
gonna get our second VPN up and running
in record time we're going yeah we're
goin again we're going again we're going
again there's maybe the last try for
today but we're going again that's for
damn sure
and then after this after this I'm
actually gonna be streaming on Twitch
after this so if you guys want to see me
play some more games and stuff uh but do
much more casual stuff than this not
have heart attacks constantly alright
let's go let's go come on buddy let's go
buddy let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go come on
fly low into my mouth just drop it on me
come on
and sputter video gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
let's go yes this is live hello yes it
is absolutely live so you can experience
the terror just with me you can
experience the risk and a horrible arse
that awaited me in the darkness bail
Marc out of jail would you guys bail me
out of jail it really depends on what I
go to jail for right if it's something
uh I mean what would I be going for jail
for that you guys wouldn't pretty much
everything that I could possibly do that
would land me in jail would look kind of
like stop you guys from bailing me out
of jail right pretty much no no this is
like ten pounds of heroin yeah that's
probably bad you shouldn't bail me let's
just go ahead don't family out of jail
if I'm doing something unless I'm
investigating the Deep Web to try to
save some poor lady that's uh in a
horrible situation
then I guess bail me out of jail sure
let's go without I went up one two money
go to the doll market I don't want to go
to the doll market all right well if the
doll mark is there I'm gonna go to the
doll market but I got to put down the
VPN first anyway blaster
gimme you give me you know blast of
course of course you would yeah you
shouldn't you shouldn't
absolutely new new and improved spots
seems like the fifth floor there must
have been on the sixth floor that I just
overlooked right maybe I'm just stupid
maybe maybe maybe the answer is that I
am dumb see fifth floor no longer one so
they do randomize the spots of where
those are good
who'da thunk 'old you would go to jail
for not locking the flashlight I don't
think that's I don't think that's how
any I don't even know of one single
flashlight that operates based on a
locking mechanism so I think you need to
pull your head out of your own ass I'm a
locket I am locking the door everybody
I'm locking the door unlocking the
people I'm locking the lights
and yeah that's that's it okay maybe I
should just wait and let let the daus
coin farm up maybe that's the only way
to properly win this right because how
else are you gonna make das coin he's
gotta wait right it's got a whole lot of
waiting all right let's do this again
first I'm gonna buy another backdoor
hack Oh smack OH
backdoor hack all right let's go on
let's get EOD and let's see if the
dollmaker is there I didn't see the
dollmaker before but I may have just
been mistaken all right let's go come on
come on come on we got places to be
flashlight is life they are [ __ ] you
over
what's my twitch twitch TV slash
markiplier it's pretty simple alright
doll doll doll where's the doll maker
the dollmaker is not here not here which
just means that we're gonna have a
problem
Ave Satan Ave Satan whatever we're gonna
change
Wi-Fi is very frequently just because I
can
nope okay that's a dead end easy
I'm pissed if you if you couldn't tell
I'm pissed
cheap surgery clicking back and forth on
what forces a hack if Ike Oh can I like
back and forth is that faster yeah
doesn't seem to be any faster
yeah lock the air oh you guys are so
silly all the time you guys are just a
silly Billy aren't you oh you silly
Billy's alright the doll mate don't do
dollmaker I can't do doll maker doll
maker doesn't even exist I would have to
wait till like the next night to be able
to do anything like that on crave don't
break the 9 well it wasn't planning on
it but you know maybe I won't this time
oh boy don't like that alright do not
break the 9 don't break it don't break
the 9 don't 9 break no don't do that
nothing but the end alright there's
nothing clickable here nothing in the
source code
I don't think out wait not wait what
what are we looking at before I am the
Lord oh this is clickable hey cool
alright cool cool cool wouldn't have
known that alright cool cool cool yeah
oh yeah no wait I did find this before
all right that didn't help me at all
great
great wonderful great wonderful I'm so
happy I didn't even see there may have
been something there and I just nope
doubt of it but I don't know all right I
oh good old I page
yep just that freaking I why is there an
eye there there's nothing to the eye the
website was named beef all right I'm
gonna wait till that goes and then I'm
gonna move the Wi-Fi up okay moving lap
I'm just gonna operate on the free Wi-Fi
for the time being and then hope for the
best really really there we go grandma
who grandma are you talking about
grandma also I hate how it doesn't go to
the homepage if it's unable to a tunic
developers that's a bug if you connect
to a different Wi-Fi and then you hit
the home page again it doesn't go it's
[ __ ] I'm good to [ __ ] for your
[ __ ] all right
57 random mysterious page whose goddamn
right it is you're goddamn right
also let me go ahead and preemptively
click turn off the light in here nope
nothing what's his twitch name it's just
markiplier it's just markiplier I've had
that twitch for six years now less than
five and a half years now I don't think
anything's gonna kill me this early in
the night but you really never know with
this game there could be some [ __ ]
that decides to slap you in the ass on
the way to a randomly innocuous Deep Web
web site and also not every Deep Web web
site is all about this horrible semen
milk trading pedophilia cat [ __ ] like
horribleness as far as I know maybe it
is who knows get my mom to play this my
mom wouldn't even know where to stop my
mom would not have the patience for this
game I don't even have the patience for
this game oh boy foot fetish well like
it I like it a lot my favorite food oh
boy I don't know why everybody on the
Deep Web as a southern accent they're a
mockery of a southern accent but they do
they do and you can't tell me otherwise
there is no doll maker not on this one I
don't have it doesn't don't exist
alright homemade homemade sweet
marmalade and feed combo the best of the
best and I'm gonna change it over to TCP
oops goddamnit I was right there
frickin dick okay why are you looking at
the door on the left because somebody
could be standing outside that door
that's why I'm looking at the door of
the left it's easy to get rid of those
people but they could be standing out
there all right would have got these
homemade yep send me pics if you're as
horny as I am right now just thinking
about it send me a message nope
how can you talk dirty about feet anyway
I was stepping in some mud today good
catching crawdads out on the swamp and I
got my footsies real dirty Oh God tell
me about your Tootsie's and how dirty
they be oh let me tell you those the
dirtiest crawdad Tootsie's you ever did
find oh my god I am so aroused at this
juncture me too all right I don't know
where that fantasy went but something
tells me we should never revisit it ever
again anybody outside my door hearing me
talking about this is southern cousins
the southern crowd seed cousins Oh pick
another fortune all right that helps you
know one time I got a fortune while I
was out on the Prairie oh my god were
you barefoot out on that prayer you know
it goes never mind
I'm gonna go away from this is the worst
thing I've ever said and the entirety of
forever I don't know why I keep checking
out there I mean unless I hear something
I don't think anybody's gonna actually
be there
hail Satan let's go to hell what are you
doing in my swamp shrek I didn't know
that I was in your swamp looking for
crawdads well now that you're here you
could give me a footsie Tootsie massage
oh-ho Shrek I've always wanted to give
you a foot c2z massage what happened to
your accent lost it in the war along
with my shoes okay anyway I'm sorry I'm
sorry for the way that I am I'm really
sorry actually I'm honestly please
forgive me please I beg you
I beg your forgiveness I beg it let's go
to this last one then we're gonna switch
wife eyes oh no you know what I'm gonna
go ahead and switch Wi-Fi this one's
gonna take a bit what though what no I
but I was what oh I'm not connected to
anything oh of course
oops my bad mmm marks king shaming I'm
not king shaming but I'm king shaming
I'm king shaming you to give me a ditsy
rule that's what I call my special move
when I take my Tootsie's and put them on
your fat rolls wrong with me this is
just the crack out the crawdads swamp
madness ain't no ain't nobody gonna
wanna come near my disease
I've kind of lost my mind while playing
this game I don't know don't don't don't
just don't just everybody stop and run
run away from me you know don't turn off
your computer just run run as far and as
fast as you can
there's really no way there's really no
way that anybody is safe here
southern player I don't want to be known
as that nothing wrong with me there's
nothing wrong with a little Tutsi footsy
love anyway look it's a pickled dirt see
I've been dreaming of that day whatever
anything here doesn't look like it yep a
whole lot of nothing okay one more and
then we're gonna trade out I've only got
18.4 daus coin I need more hacks to be
able to get more money ain't gonna
happen you'll run as far and as fast as
you can to show me your tootsies please
don't this is an act this is an act
please this is a this is a joke this is
not real this is a trip don't don't do
no please I don't have a foot fetish but
southern priors Canon foot fetish to the
extreme if there's one thing I like well
for surfing barefoot hanging tan on a
southern surfboard though if you don't
know what a southern surfboard is I'll
tell you whoa oh god not this place okay
you know what I don't want that the only
answer is
I'm not there I oh okay all right I sure
how are you I'm fine all right let's
fail this memory defrag err is it like a
combo what you get based on this six
three easy easy money
I got money baby I got twenty three
point two five I'm very close to getting
what I need I'm gonna switch this to
outside and then we're gonna be good
okay all right stop watching TV for this
you stop watching TV for this what about
the foot fit touch the swamp cousins
we don't do nothing else but give each
other foot massages what you guys want
to know what you guys want to know what
hanging ten off a southern surfboard
means well let me describe it to you in
not untold detail it's a very risky
maneuver sorry I'm losing my southern
accent it's a very risky maneuver you go
out on the swamp and you find yourself a
gator and once you get on that Gator you
risky your tootsies by dangling it over
the mouth hole of that Gator
I didn't buy out goddamnit I didn't buy
it
[Music]
goddamnit what the oh no I was fine
sorry I was fine donut god dammit I
could have had the money I needed I
didn't think I was gonna get hacked
twice in a row alright yeah did I lock
the air yet you know what Noah didn't
and that's my fault I'm at the wrong
here alright I'm about to get enough
money to be able to get another one so
me go to the shadow market I'm gonna get
me a VPN point got it okay that's
shipping let's go back online go home
where are we
10:35 I should probably cycle back to my
desk
Sooni okay tango down hitman for hire I
hope that doesn't trigger the actual
hitman to come find me because I don't
want that don't want that at all
nope can't even go there that's great
okay
there's shipped yet shipping still it's
gonna be a bit that's gonna be a spell
all right whatever
thanks for visiting just random
gibberish I do love me some random
gibberish I mean along with my other
interests such as Tutsis and southern
serve Morden oh no it's this place well
this isn't gonna give me anything is it
you know I must save this for later I
don't know if that's actually gonna help
lock the [ __ ] air I can't lock the
air I don't have the intellectual
capacity to do such a maneuver butcher
proper ways of butchering the human body
great great great great
what about what would happen if I just
would have happened if I just get the
VPNs and then don't go on the internet
for like a long time what if I just hide
in my shower and leave the game running
for like an hour what happened
uh-oh no I'll try it maybe the gray I
don't want to whoop there goes my window
my window is now open
goddamn you goddamn you and your
tootsies goddamn you and your sweet
succulent Tootsie's my god
heard something I don't like it I don't
like it
mm-hmm I don't like it I'm gonna yeah I
don't like it I don't like it
where's my Wi-Fi I don't like it I just
don't want to be I just don't want to
risk it mm-hmm I don't like it oh and
let me buy another what the [ __ ] is that
sound you guys hearing that wait wait
wait wait wait
power enough you hear that I don't trust
I have not found any I have not found
any source codes I'm not gonna touch see
little lock that seems impossible
I don't think thousand explain anything
there but if there was if there was
anything there then
I can't lock my lungs there's only so
many things that I could possibly lock
no I refuse to lock my dude sees there's
no way that you could make me lock my
dad sees that would be the last thing
that I would ever do all right
either way my VPN is waiting for me
downstairs all right
my VPN is waiting for me just gonna go
get it
oops it's locked oops I locked the door
let's go get the VPN and that's it we're
gonna go get the VPN we're gonna go in
the door we're hopefully not gonna get
stabbed by the breather and we're gonna
be fine can't you see by my reassuring
smile is that we're all gonna be fine
everything's gonna be hunky-dory gonna
be fine you know what they say if it's
hunky do your pants no fill with poo
okay all right I don't know what the
honk was I don't like random honking I
played enough horror games to know that
random honking is a bad thing I think I
think that everything is good zzzz my
Tootsie's are busy okay we're gonna book
it
I can't lock the honking the honking is
unlockable I'm not gonna die yeah that's
fine I don't think there's anyone there
breather no breezy breather no breathing
why does it look like it says hunter
looks like the name says Cu Pentti on it
it says Clint looks a lot like it says
[ __ ] and I don't appreciate that
name-calling very much soup delivery I
hope they don't suit me I don't want any
soup it's walk the honk I can't lock the
air what how do you mean walk the
pooping I'll put some duct tape over my
butthole that'll lock that poop tray
right
you guys here's some very loud thumping
that might have been outside my house
but it sounded like some light thumping
all right great great great wonderful
giddy and just to prove a point you
can't lock the door when you come back
there's no locking you know happen like
that all right so now we just got to
find a spot for this it sounded like a
long intake of breath not just like oh
no those me breathing normally like the
doza those a breath that was breath that
was a strong breath oh boy okay so I
already placed one in five but I'm still
a little worried about the whole you
know breath situation
okay I'm [ __ ] I'm very [ __ ] I'm
unbelievably [ __ ] I'm so far I'm dead
I am dead
I am straight-up dead Hey look I got a
good VPN position but I'm dead
I don't know if this helps at all I
don't know but but it might help don't
know there was a lot of breath happening
there was a lot of breath happening it
may be like one of them was in my
apartment because I technically only
stepped in to grab the VPN and then I
went right out but that wouldn't make
much sense why there would be in the
apartment and didn't kill me I don't
know I just know what I heard and I know
that this game is an unpredictable
douche
there we go oh that's not good okay
that's home sweet home mm-hmm great
great great
we're back I guess not safe even
remotely in fact less safe than I just
was you know I'm not gonna go on this
Wi-Fi no maybe I don't remember which
Wi-Fi I was on more than the other or
whatever okay
all right let's I was trying to buy a
hack I was trying to buy a hack
prevention that's exactly what I was
doing I was literally buying a backdoor
hack block and I'm gonna need to buy sky
break now cuz I'm gonna have to break
the things ok the hall don't enter
that's where I died before let's go back
into the hall huh that's a good idea
let's go back into the hall
boy yep don't like the hall source code
looks like ass yeah I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna say I'm not gonna stay in the
hall nope no that's still going I'm
trying to leave and it's still going I
don't like that I don't like that Oh
nope still going okay you know what I'm
just connecting nope nope nope not gonna
do that
nope nope
nope nope nope nope outta there lock
down the hall everybody lock down the
hall the law the hall needs to be locked
real tight okay we're just gonna scan
we're not even gonna poop swept we're
gonna scan we're just gonna scan we're
not actually gonna do anything we're
just gonna scan for these things and
we're gonna break into them we're not
even connected the internet so we don't
have to worry about anything probe why
wi the 7b8
nope 7l h h1 1000 okay that's gonna do
that thing we're just gonna work
schedule
now I'm gonna go just cuz all right
we're fine we're fine
we're if we have four dollars and 32
cents we don't have much else to go for
it's pretty much all locked up at this
point we're only gonna stay on this for
a little bit and then we're gonna move
over to the other one because I want to
keep moving around I know these guys
well that's weird
okay all right in Lourdes people the
saved I don't think they wanted to be
saved just a hunch
also how many of these religious cults
are or competent people that are able to
build websites on the Deep Web that's it
seems like a an overwhelming amount
there's still much to be done
okay I don't see anything else here
nothing else here that I see nope okay I
don't know okay we're gonna I'm just
gonna hop off I'm gonna disconnect
actually I'm gonna hop to the other one
oh here look out the window
nothing okay we're gonna six seven one
twelve
crack crack that we only get one more
for we rock and then pretty much that's
all we got I've explored every site and
I don't know what else to do other than
wait and hope for money as it falls into
my lap okay we rock we have many names
great okay nothing there let me see this
nope doesn't look like anything okay I
don't exactly know what to do p WF one
three eight two four four five
Pass is five four three two one got it
okay that's in there we've got a whole
lot of nobody
okay let's just move again just because
super paranoid about it let's disconnect
and I'm like so paranoid I don't even
know why like I just suddenly become
ultra paranoid about anything and
everything all right let's go for here
let's scan seven $7.50 I'll keep you
updated on how much money I've got don't
worry I'm not gonna move my webcam are
you crazy you out of your mind
yay one eight okay that's probing all
right literally I don't know what other
fed fed fed fed fed fed fed is that what
it always was I don't like that I don't
like that at all I don't like fresh new
links Ave Satan okay my window is open
no he was open never mind he was always
open I don't know I just panicked about
that oh my god
nothing okay yeah lock the webcam in
place you you better believe your ass
I'm gonna lock this webcam in place what
the [ __ ] was that can you do that seven
right okay what else do I even do I
don't even know which one of these would
would be available now yeah there's got
to be one of these that are suddenly
available now there was also that other
one No come here you Wi-Fi a f-105d pass
okay got that I'm gonna disconnect I
just don't I don't feel safe at all I
mean by all accounts the police should
be the easiest to avoid cuz hopefully
you hear them on the way and I'm pretty
sure I only got caught because that
other one that other one flubbed me over
he was either the website or the Wi-Fi
that I connected to I don't know
hide why do I need to hide did you Fed
or the cops Fed is just the name of the
homepage I'm thinking maybe I'm gonna
find another Wi-Fi before I connect to
anything else because I don't know if
actually there's actually gonna be a
benefit to doing anything else anyway
alright let's go to probe 1ww QD f w 0 k
1000 please yeah the only thing I can
hope for is that if I was online I could
be hacked like that's the only thing
that I could hope for nothing else I
know there's so many noises is
constantly noises fat equals police I
doubt that very much
no that's just the name of the homepage
I think the whole point of this game is
you have to wait for money like the idea
is just not to go as far into the Deep
Web as you would hope it's like hope for
and just wait in the shower I think it's
just this is a shower simulator game you
just got to take the world's longest
shower while you wait for your money to
appear what was that other one thanks
for visiting was that the one yeah I
think that was the one with all the the
numbers and [ __ ] and maybe that'll have
something I doubt it but okay we're good
that was easier than I thought if I
could spam click it's all good it's all
gooey
come on hurry up resilient I'm 46
you log off wait what the [ __ ] 46 for 40
40 46 for forty gold mine
don't let god I have now 59 holy [ __ ]
hang on let me I gotta crack this nope
that's crackle you're thinking of snap
crackle pop I have so much money right
now I don't want to lose it okay I have
so much money right now I have so much
money
lock okay life is so much money I have
so much to lose okay all right so no no
stop that
so reoccur pass sunshine let's go to
that one for now
let's go to freeter password sunshine
because I need to go to the market
that's the only reason I need the market
for one of these and then maybe I should
get a motion sensor that's probably a
motion sensor put it right outside my
door they'd be awfully nice
so either way I've got I've got a VPN on
the way if I could get two if I could
get 2 VPNs that'd be great
both two more VPNs that this lot of
money it's a lot of money
out of money sure no [ __ ] try how do
I turn it off I've totally forgotten
power off dude
[Music]
I think it's fine
I think it's fine I think everything's
okay
I don't hear anyone so okay anything god
[Music]
no there weren't footsteps there weren't
there weren't footsteps no there were
not footsteps I didn't hear [ __ ] [ __ ] no
I did there was nothing there was
nothing
I'm listening at a barracks where there
was nothing there was nothing
alright alright that's gonna be it for
today
that's gonna be it for today that's
gonna be it for today you were you or
fooling yourself that's gonna be it for
today I probably should have waited like
longer just in case it does say with
Lucas that was Lucas by the way he's the
assassin that uh if you hide for five
minutes he'll probably go away but there
are times when it says there are times
when he said he waited for five minutes
and went back and he didn't hear
anything and he shot him anyways so it
just means he's dead so it means I what
I probably didn't get to the bathroom
fast enough because I flubbed everything
but it's fine alright anyway so I'm
gonna get out of here that was a fun
time I'm also gonna be streaming over on
Twitch right after this probably
starting around 2:00 p.m. my time which
is in about 40 minutes so if you want to
go over there follow me on twitch TV
slash markiplier I'm gonna stream and
more casual stuff less stressful
heart-pounding things and I should be a
fun day of the stream and yeah so check
me out over there I will see you in just
a bit if you're gonna come over thank
you everybody so much for watching I'll
pick this up back again we'll do another
live stream of this again because it's
super fun to do and I want to beat it
now it's not gonna beat me so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye bye guys see over there bye